dalia quiere comprar una parcela sobre
la cual construir su casa ya redujo su
búsqueda a dos parcelas que tienen buena
ubicación la parcela envía manzana 3 1
4159 tiene un ancho de 30 metros y un
largo de 40 metros guau va a ser una
casa muy grande es esta de acá la
parcela encerrada fibonacci 1 1 2 3 5
tiene ancho de 50 metros 50 metros y
largo de 20 metros es esta de acá cada
una se vende en 360 mil pesos cuál es
una mejor compra bueno pues como ya nos
dicen que ambas tienen buena ubicación y
ambas cuestan lo mismo el criterio que
vamos a utilizar es pues la que sea más
grande la que ocupe más espacio así que
te invito a que detengas este vídeo e
intentes por tu cuenta calcular cuál de
estas dos parcelas tiene más espacio
ocupa más espacio sale bueno lo vamos a
hacer ahorita esto de ocupar más espacio
tiene que ver con el área y como ya
vimos en vídeos pasados
el área de un rectángulo se puede
calcular multiplicando sus dimensiones
en este caso tendríamos que multiplicar
el ancho por el largo pues ambas
parcelas son rectangulares vale entonces
vamos a empezar con la de la izquierda
con la parcela debía manzana voy a bajar
tantito el área voy a tomar el color
azul que es el color debía manzana el
área
de esta parcela sería igual a 40 metros
40 metros por 30 metros 30 metros y eso
es igual a 40 por 30 es mil 200 mil 200
metros por metro 6 metros cuadrados
metros
metros cuadrados cuadrados muy bien ese
es el área de esta parcela y qué sucede
con la parcela que está encerrada
fibonacci bueno el área el área
una vez más sería multiplicar sus
dimensiones es decir sería 20 metros por
50 metros 20 metros por 50 metros 20 por
50 es 1000 entonces sería el área sería
de 1000 metros metros metros cuadrados
cuadrados vale entonces bueno ambas
parcelas tienen buena ubicación y
cuestan lo mismo pero como la parcela
debía manzana tiene más área entonces es
la que conviene más y esto de 1.200
metros cuadrados recuerda que
simplemente quiere decir que aquí si
ponemos cuadraditos de lado uno de un
metro por un metro
entonces caben 1200 y de manera similar
aquí si ponemos cuadraditos de un metro
por un metro
nada más caben mil entonces de aquí se
ve que la parcela envía manzana es una
mejor oferta